my name is john armstrong i'm a lecturer
and fellow in the design program at
stanford and some of the courses I teach
are designing her life designing your
Stanford and designing the professional
and the content that we worked on in
this workshop was a set of videos which
fee PTL had actually previously helped
us create which we then throughout the
course of the teaching with technology
workshop moved into an online blended
learning format available to students on
campus the general public as well as
other departments and professionals
across the university at Stanford when
we started the teaching with technology
workshop we had a set of completed
animated videos which we had created
prior with fee ptl's support but the
workshop over the course of the few
months that we were part of the workshop
we spent that time interviewing users
understanding how we could frame those
videos in the most useful way to the
people we were trying to target and then
working with Phoebe teal staff to revise
and actually fit the content into an
appropriate format for this platform
here in a way that would hit Stanford
students but also be available and
accessible to the general public some of
the most valuable things were first of
all working in a structured way with VP
TL staff and getting concrete feedback
on how our learning goals actually
matched the product or our platform that
we were creating that was one another
was just the opportunity to work with
other colleagues on campus and getting
their feedback coming from very
different perspectives then then our own
because they were from different
departments or had different types of
projects they were working on that was
very interesting and very valuable for
us and then the third I think connected
to the other two was just being able to
have a good balance between flexibility
and creative autonomy but within the
structure of a workshop format and
within the guidance of being able to
have support on this specific platform
and a general guideline for the scope
and content of the project